Hearing a lot about the Internet of
things,
how your many,
many devices are becoming networked
computers and many of these devices are
you know,
$10 thing that you buy and you put on
your shelf and you have it for year and
you throw it away.
Um,
I think not a lot of attention is being
played,
paid to the security of those kinds of
devices and some sense of the companies
that are making them can't afford to do
it.
Um,
but they,
they can leave longstanding
vulnerabilities.
The automotive industry is another
interesting example.
A typical American modern automobile.
How somewhere between 30 and a hundred
would have called embedded control
units,
but in better control unit is just a
computer.
Some of them are very,
very small and run very simple code.
A native on the hardware.
Some of them are full blown linux
computers or,
or windows computers and they are
networked.
A modern car has four to five network
connections where the code,
the computers on the car talked to
computers outside of the car.
So an example is there's a bluetooth
connection so that your cell phone can
talk to the car so that you can play
your music from your phone on the car or
you can talk on the cell phone without
having,
you're having to use your hands.
There's also a telematics unit,
which is the thing that um,
if you get in an accident,
we'll arrange to call nine one one or
have the paramedics come that that
service,
which is really useful and very,
uh,
it's a great safety feature means that
your car has a cell phone number and
that it's possible to communicate with
your car over that cell phone
connection.
Hackers can use those network
connections to remotely break in to the
computer system that's on your car and
white hat hackers have shown they can do
that and then they can then rewrite any
of the software on the car,
replaced the code that was legitimately
put there by the car manufacturer with
whatever code they want to have there.
And a typical,
uh,
you know,
modern car,
pretty much all of the functionality of
the car is now controlled by software.
So breaking is controlled site by
software because you really want to have
antilock braking steer,
um,
uh,
acceleration is controlled by software
because of cruise control and when you
like you really want to have a car that
can park parallel parking for you.
That means steering is under software
control.
The locks are under software control so
you can push the key fob button and have
your locks open.
Uh,
essentially all of the functionality of
cars or under software control.
And for the most part,
that's a really good thing.
Having it be under software control
means that you can get increased
functionality,
you can have improved safety features,
you can get upgrades as the car
companies figured out how to do things
better.
All of that's really good.
Um,
the downside is that because it's
controlled by software,
if an attacker can come in and replace
that software,
then they can control the braking and
the acceleration and the locks and
everything that it was under software
control.
So we're starting to see theft rings,
for example,
that are using electronic hacking in
order to steal cars more easily.
Lloyd's of London recently stopped
insuring land rovers in England unless
the land rovers where garaged in a
locked facility because they were being
stolen too frequently.
So that's the kind of state of the art
of the automotive industry.
The question is,
well,
why isn't it better?
So one starting point is it's really
hard to get good security.
You have to do tons of things right.
It costs money.
So the car industry could improve the
security of their cars and hopefully
they will eventually,
um,
that improvement will cost them money.
And the car industry doesn't have huge
profit margins.
They can't really afford to invest in
the security unless they can recoup the
costs associated with that investment by
passing the cost onto the consumer.
So that means the price of the car is
going to be higher.
Um,
so then why is the consumer going to go
buy the car?
That's more than the equivalent car from
a different manufacturer will typically
the answers while you do advertising,
you explain to the consumer why they're
getting more value for this extra cost.
The problem is if you,
if you imagine car company,
a car company starting a ad campaign to
explain their car is more cyber secure.
Most consumers these days probably think
their car was already cybersecurity.
They didn't realize that their car could
be hacked into.
So the result of such an advertising
campaign could in fact be to make people
afraid to buy any new car whatsoever
rather than causing them to buy a
particular car.
So I think an advertising approach to
motivating consumers to pay slightly
more for a particular car is not really
viable.
So that means all of the cars have to
have,
like basically all of the companies have
to do it at the same time.
They all have to do this extra
investment that basically if the price
of old cars goes up by a little bit,
then there's no longer this
differentiation between manufacturers
and consumers would be choosing between
cars that all have roughly the same
level of security.
Um,
going back just a bit,
another reason why the car companies
can't advertise on the security is
suppose one car company actually did go
and invest a ton in making their cars
more secure and then they advertise
their car was more secure.
That's kind of a painting,
a big target on your back as far as the
hacker community is concerned.
Certain uh,
individuals would take that as a
challenge and they would go like they
would,
you sort of get some number of
credibility for hacking into any car.
But if you hack into the car that is
from the company that is advertising
that their cars are secure,
you get way more credibility if they
find a vulnerability and then publish
it.
That car all of a sudden has less,
is less secure than the other cars that
might actually have more
vulnerabilities,
but no one has discovered it because the
vulnerability is public and people know
it exists and therefore can exploit it.
So it's this weird situation where
although the car in some absolute sense
is more secure in a practical sense,
it's less secure because there's a
publicly known vulnerability.
So advertising is bad both because it
could scare away consumers entirely and
they could direct hackers to your
specific car,
decreasing the security of that car.
And uh,
as a result.
So we're left with how do you get sort
of the car industry as a whole to
produce more secure cars and that
requires some kind of external
motivation.
They might decide to do it because it's
just the right thing to do.
Typically companies are motivated by
financial reasons,
not,
they usually can't afford to do things
just because of the right thing to do.
Um,
in terms of outside forces,
uh,
one outside force would be government
regulation.
So cars many years ago were very unsafe,
right?
Ralph Nader wrote famously unsafe at any
speed,
not prompted,
uh,
federal regulations.
There's the five star safety crash
rating,
a system,
for example,
that that created a regime where cars
were tested for their safety and given
scores and consumers could then use
those scores and making their decisions.
I think creating such a regime in the
current political climate is unlikely.
Um,
another possibility is the insurance
company might,
the insurance industry might start to
impose,
put pressure,
financial pressure on car industry.
We saw that with the Lloyd's of London
refusing to ensure land rovers that
weren't garaged in locked facilities
because of electronic theft,
that if the insurance companies start to
notice that certain kinds of cars are
getting hacked into with negative
consequences for theft or for accidents,
they might increase the insurance
premiums on that particular brand and
those insurance premium is,
might then drive consumers to cars that
don't have those characteristics and
that might then motivate the car
industry to improve the security.
That's kind of a long chain,
but at the moment I think that's my best
guess as to how we'll get better
cybersecurity and in our cars.
But I think the car industry is in some
sense representative of many other
industries.
So like medical devices or another
domain,
things like pacemakers and insulin
pumps.
They are relatively simple computer
systems that are networked to other
computers.
Like it makes sense for a pacemaker to
have a wifi device so a doctor can
monitor how the heart's you doing.
But once you have that wifi connection,
a hacker can use it to go in and modify
the code and the pacemaker.
There are basically lots of examples of
industries where things that previously
weren't computers at all are now not
only computers where their networks,
computers,
and over time those industries will need
to accept that their network computers
and start to apply security techniques
so that the systems are,
are more secure.